[Music]
hello everyone i'm grand master dennis
borsch and this is
insane in the end game and this time
we are going to look at some
special games from the 80s
and 70s where we had
quite spectacular champions of that
time so we're going to look from
an olympic champions perspective it's
going to be the first game
and the second one will be from the
birthday boy
i don't know if you if you know it but
a swedish legend has just turned
70 recently so stick around
to know which game we're looking at
in this review alright so
the first game is ripley versus karpov
played in the 70s and little did they
know
at that moment that this will become a
rivalry
not the corp of kasparov level rivalry
but a a rivalry nonetheless
where karpov will get some hardships
ripley if you did not know is
well known for his positional touch
which actually became more prominent
like his style
does reflect on modern day chess and you
often see that
return so let's start with this one the
opening
really does not interest us
it's something that is non-standard
what we're more interested in is this
position now if you just look at it
we can notice that karpov
gets very good counter play the king is
safe
all is very good but
on the other hand black will have to
deal with these
doubled pawns on a6 and a4
while this c7 and d6 is somewhat
backwards usually pawn centers
are on d5 and the pawn is on c6
right supporting that however ribley who
is an olympic
champion and a very good very strong
player
in his own right is making sure that
never really happens
obviously queen d7 doesn't work just yet
because that would lead to a piece loss
via rook takes e7
so instead rook e8 happens and here
comes the first question
that is something that we need to
understand
so once ribley gets a good
uh stranglehold on the position he nev
excuse me never lets it go so
let's think about weights how ripley can
keep that pressure on and keep it going
so it is a white to move and keep the
pressure going it's not
as much of a tactical way of
attacking the position but more of the
slow
grindy and techniquey way of playing
yes correct here white goes knight c3
instead of queen takes a4 that's a great
suggestion
by the chat if you go queen takes a4
you are letting loose this grip
and karpov can start pushing the c
and d pawns and black sort of starts
breathing much easier after this move of
knight c3
there is still a stranglehold on
those critical squares and white
will be able to nudge that pawn
knight c3 queen d7
now the trade is possible as the e7
bishop
is defended takes knight takes
knight takes a4 and strictly speaking
this is not a catalan
but there are catalan methods
and thoughts that are very similar to
this one
black has a somewhat damaged pawn
structure
and ribley is going to use that with
maximum effect so before we get into the
meaty part and the nitty-gritty part
which one of the pawns can we try to
undermine as
white in this position of course
right now it's very hard to get to them
but we
can already have an idea
which bonds will become future
weaknesses
well at the moment it's very difficult
to have
mating threats when there are absolutely
no attacking pieces
on the board and the queens are traded
off
so in order to
actually call upon weak you have to find
a way
to attack them so
let's say if you talk about the apon
there
it's very difficult to attack it so
technically it can become a weakness and
of course
will become one but at the moment it's
very difficult to get to
but there is a pawn that we can try to
pressure in this position
yes indeed that's the c7 pawn so we
found our target we just need to find a
way
to come and sneak on closer
to it bishop d2
bishop a5 very very good
and ribley does that exactly he
goes after that pawn with this plan
over defending this square and then
going for bishop a5
that pawn is going to become a weakness
and now you can
wonder well the knight is not supposed
to be on the rim right
well that is true however it defends an
important pawn on b2 and controls
critical squares
on c5 and b6 if for example
black would go knight c5 why would be
able to capture
pawn captures rogue b1 takes
bishop takes and even though it's
material equality
black has way too many pawn weaknesses
to
claim that the position is even in fact
it's white who will call the shots and
after an eventual b3
and a king maneuver up to e2 d3
and c4 black will be struggling
not to lose this end game
so this knight is not to be
underestimated because of that
bishop d2 rook e6
now if you look at the position we can
note that it is black who has less space
black's pawns are a little bit loose
so a we either want to attack them
as we mentioned we can try something
like bishop a5
or fix these ones and this is the plan
the plan that ribley chooses so rook d1
rookie eight king f1 very very simple
plan
he's not afraid to trade he knows in the
long run
even without the rooks or
a pair of rooks white will get a chance
to move on with the attack
so king f1 king f8
so far so good white does nurse a small
advantage
but how can we build a bigger one and
that is actually the struggle
that most novices face
they get a good position but they're
uncertain how to continue
and surprisingly enough this game was a
youth
game between ribley and carpool then
just shows
how much of a talent ripley had at that
time and of course
still does so how can we
try to build and restrict carpool's play
in this position
so oftentimes um we kind of
at a loss what to do it happens more
often than we
uh care to actually admit
but a lot of times it has to do with
realizing what karpov would play
if he was on move if karpov was
to move he definitely would like to go
c6 and d5
build a very very stable situation in
that case
if black can get claim in the center
he's going to be doing all right
so ribley's choice should be to somehow
push that back or stop that
bishop c3 makes sense but if you go
bishop c3
you are forcing trades yes you get rid
of this bishop on f6
but after multiple trades your advantage
is dissipating and karpov will get that
d5 move in
which will mean that black
is very close to draw the game or at
least
even it out
so many paths and ultimately one defined
solution
um not always actually
there are multiple ways leading to rome
and that's that goes for chess too a
couple of other things that you can play
here
that would still be very successful
as it suggested in chat c4 is a great
move i like it
um it wasn't played by ribley but
that would solve our problem no more d5
and karpov would have to look for a
different plan
ripley actually plays b3 first
making sure that karpov doesn't have a
single target
on the long diagonal rook takes c1
bishop takes c1 so ribley knows that
with every trade his advantage just
dissipates
so instead of trading one more pair of
rooks he's keeping
one on the board and also stopping that
d5 plan
rookie five and c4
and this is what i was saying even
though
ribley played b3 and you suggested c4
that does not mean that your c for
suggestion is bad
it's just the way that ribley decided to
play the position
yeah definitely if we could we'd love to
get that knight to d5
although we have to be mindful of a
potential c6 which would boot our knight
from that juicy square
c4 g6
okay so we accomplished a lot we've got
the central control
karpov can't untangle easily we've got
direct pressure on that pawn on d6 so
that's not going to happen anytime soon
now is there any potential trades
that karpov should or could
try to accomplish
let's see after potential moves of king
g7
and rook f5 or just king g7
and some other moves
well black clearly wants to trade the
knights if possible
because if the knights are traded off
it's very difficult
to just come close to the c pawn
like once the knight would head to d5
it's much harder to deal with those type
of threats
so ribley does what most of the best
technicians
and technical technical players do he
restricts
so bishop b4 isn't necessarily trying to
uh have like a direct threat it's just
trying to take away
a potential knight c5 idea if
black goes knight c5 ripley might just
choose bishop takes
pawn takes and knight to c3 and it's not
that this is winning on the spot but the
knight is just superior
to a bishop that doesn't have a single
target
on the long diagonal naturally karpov
doesn't want to get into that and goes
rook f5
bishop d2 a little bit of maneuvering to
and fro
and um you might be a little bit
confused by this
and that's reasonable but probably
ribley decides
that instead of occupying
and stopping knight c5 from b4 he might
just get the bishop to e3 instead
where it will support a potential c5
break
and that would be more conducive to his
plans
bishop d4 karpov is resisting
korpov is resisting that idea
and seemingly successfully however
ribley finds a way to outsmart karpov
in this case what did ripley do
yep play bishop h6 check
now karpov has to react it's a double
attack
so bishop g7 is practically forced if
you don't
do that you're going to lose the bishop
now he goes back to e3 and this is that
subtle maneuvering
that makes a positional genius you
give a little check and suddenly out of
nowhere
you get a bigger advantage bishop e3
knight e5 and
unlike when you're playing tactical
chess
you're trying to come with shots after
shots
and try to win however when
you're playing more positional or
strategic
chess it's all about understanding your
opponent's plans and ideas
so we've got to understand what karpov
is about in this case
so we got to understand why karpov
played knight e5 of course
that knight is very very pretty in the
middle of the board
supported by that charger pawn on d6
providing a good outpost and some good
coordination
but there are some direct threats we
have to worry about
and of course ripley will make sure they
never happen
so we might be considering moves such as
c5 but if we do
we completely ignore what karpov is
setting up if we go c5
bam knight g4 and suddenly an advantage
that looked
very very comfortable just falls apart
so ribley noticing that knight g4 is on
the cards played
h3 himself there and there is no knight
g4 and c5 is still on the table
and this is the way he's trying to melt
the position
knight c6 any more threats
not a single one the bishop is
completely useless it doesn't have
a single target no threats by the night
it's time to go c5 and c5 is a
multi-purpose move here
not only do you attack the d6 spawn but
if they trade
it allows knight takes c5 and the
c and a pawn do get exposed in that case
king e7
and some people misunderstand what
strategic chess is all about
it isn't that you're not calculating
but you just put more emphasis
on maximizing the power
of the rook knight and bishop so
basically all of your pieces
and trying to make sure that they're
ideally coordinated
but that doesn't mean you can't play
forcefully
and in fact in this situation
ribley plays a forceful move
but it has a strategic idea behind it
someone unexpected but i'd like you
guys and girls to take a little time
and think about it
which one of black's pieces is
relatively good and does
a fine job holding ribley's pieces back
yes it's the rook on f5 that rook on f5
does a fine job
cutting off and disallowing
white to completely take over
g4 g4
is a dangerous move to make when there's
queens on the board
but not in this case because they're
deep
in the end game and also it gets the
extra benefit
of misplacing that rook it literally can
only go to e5
if rook f6 there's bishop g5 and
black is going to lose the exchange and
if the rogue goes to f3
white can play the simple king g2 with
the same idea
after rook f6 and bishop g5
so g4 rookie 5. however
this rook is very clumsy over there not
only does it
close up that bishop but
walks straight into this idea of knight
b6
threatening knight c8 and
also building the idea of knight c4
hitting the d6
and e5 rook
so now there are very big issues
before karpov would only have to deal
with this single threat of knight c8
but now it's doubled because of this g4
move that we played
we should have fade bishop f4 ramping up
the pressure
on the d-pawn rook e6
now again we are getting into
the most critical moment the biggest
critical
moment of all can we win the d-pawn
or should we look for a different
target
it's actually very simple whenever
you're trying to win a pawn here
it's the d-pawn this d6 pawn
we always always always
have to check if we outnumber the
defenders if we're not outnumbering them
plain and simple we're not going to win
the game or we're not going to win the
pawn
but if we do we can of course take it
so there are a couple of ways we can try
to attack the pawn
we can go knight c8 and attack that king
but in that case there's king d7
and we have nothing better than to go
back and of course
that's not what we want to do right now
there is three defenders
three attackers if the attackers
don't outnumber the defenders the
defenders win
so instead here ribley decides to shift
gears
and attempt to invade via the c
file and with the bishop
and rook completely out of place even
though they're defending the d-pawn
if you go knight e5 white can't go rook
c7 check
and this invasion will prove decisive
as karpov's pieces are just completely
jumbled up
they have no coordination whatsoever
so here karpov decides to give up a pawn
instead
and fight from there knight takes d5
check of course we take the free pawn
king d7
alright so white did get a pawn
for nothing that is a good news however
can we relax not really
the best way to bring home the bacon
as so we say in these ending positions
is to continue to pile pressure
which pawn will be our second victim
in this position
it's the asic spawn yes it's very
lonesome over there
and it's what we call isolated
so ribley immediately pounces
double attacks the rook and the pawn
luckily for karpov there is rookie for
attacking the bishop and you can't just
move anywhere
the king can take on c7 in that case
bishop g3 f5
it's getting heated it's getting heated
it's getting somewhat heated here
now we get into that
usual dilemma should we take on f5 or
should we
not take on f5
depending on the situation right we
would make a different decision
in this case we've got to remember
we are up material in an end game
so trades are great for us
so of course we gonna take it take
take and of course we're gonna take the
a6 bomb
f4 and
this is again a simple question where to
put our bishop
now if we would go h2 it would be
walled up by this f pawn so
ribley comes up with this very good move
of bishop
h4 and basically
finding a roundabout way of involving
his dog squared bishop in the game
rookie 5
rook c4 so white is very close to
winning
but he still has to be very precise and
a not to get this knight into trouble
and also b not to find himself in
any sort of tricky mating match
rook f5 b4 and b4 is a very clean move
by
zoltan ribley he is creating an outpost
for
the knight and once the knight escapes
from its captivity on a6 it's clear
that ribley is the one who's going to
win the game
king d6 b5
now you can't let this pawn run all the
way to the finish line
because it would just queen so karpov
takes
takes bishop g7 rook f7 and this is
probably the most important thing
to learn from this game even if you get
the advantage
you should not slow down
you don't have to be defensive just
because you're up ahead
you can try to look for new targets and
that's what ribley does he is putting
pressure
on karpov's lone pawn that is left on h7
bishop e5 takes that one as well
rook a5 and even though ribley is
famed for being a
technician a technical player more of a
positional
one he still spawns tactics when it's
necessary
so it is zoltan ribley to move and
come up with an elegant solution
knight to b4 yes
seemingly just dropping a knight for
nothing
but we can thank ourselves
for posting this bishop like a dozen
move ago
and now together the rook and bishop
will fight back when karpov takes the
knight
bishop e7 check and that knight is gone
so if he would have kept the bishop on
h2 we would never have this tactical
opportunity
that saves the knight on a6
which actually just leads to trade takes
rook takes bishop c5
so now ribley is doing the second step
you get the advantage but then it's time
to consolidate
notice that if he doesn't go bishop c5
let's say he goes h4
potentially after bishop d4 there could
be
some issues with very few material left
on the board
karpov might just salvage a draw that's
why he played bishop c5
over defending that square and only
proceeding
with king g2 after rook c2
bishop b6 rook
b2 bishop d8
bishop e5 and again
ribley does the roundabout way just to
pose the bishop on h4
and here karpov resigned rightfully
because after bishop g3 the
h and f pawns are going to win the game
therefore ripley one
in fine style so this wasn't exactly
a catalan but it is sort of the vibe
how you supposed to play the catalan
game and talking about the catalan
variation
we have to take a look at a legend
who was 70 just turned
70 recently and of course he
is the legend himself wolf anderson
so let's take a look at this game
let's start from over here this is of
course
a typical catalan
which is if you did not know a reverse
grundfeld variation should be seven
knight c3 so white
gets the central control however in
return
gallego his opponent gets
very very solid play b4
pushes the pawn forward knight e4
c5 so white
does not necessarily get a big of an
advantage
but his king is much safer
and occasionally this
catalan bishop becomes so powerful
that it just outshines its counterpart
on b7
now there is a need for a little bit of
introduction
for anderson anderson
is very very good at these end games
so i feel it's fitting for us to take a
look
how he converts the smallest of
advantages
in the catalog knight takes f6
knight takes f6 bishop e3
so compared to other positions
white isn't really shying away
from traits now for the initiated i
this seems like winning a piece but it
really doesn't
do that because after queen d7 takes
takes black is just mighty fine
so anderson actually doesn't mind the
trades he's saying
in the long run your pawns on a7
and b4 are becoming targets while my
pawns
are very well organized and
rather safe on the queen side
rook c8 so
even though we are in the middle game
right now
anderson already forces and pushes
gallego
to trade goes rook c1
he says i'd like you to react i'd like
you to trade and if you do
i will be able to target your queen side
gallego goes queen a5 d takes c5
now all the chess principles
do matter even in the catalan gallegos
king is still
in the center so taking on c5 would be
way too dangerous
that is why gallego decides to
temporarily sacrifice the pawn
saying that i will win it back
eventually
and he is not wrong
now we've got this extra pawn on c5
but we've got a choice to make should we
keep the
a2 pawn or the c5 pawn that is something
we
should try to find out chat
viewers which one should we keep
so i can see there is some division
which one to keep as white
well in general you should keep pawns
that are more useful for the end game
the a2 pawn is pretty
far from ever promoting on this square
however the c pawn is relatively
close to promotion therefore
anderson plays knight d4 here
so if bishop c5 like takes takes
bishop c5 there is this neat little
tactical
jump of knight b3 double attacking the
queen and bishop
basically evening on the spot
so gallego has to take on a2
knight b3 now if queen takes b2
the queen would get trapped
via bishop d4 and rook a1
so this kind of justifies
ulve's decision of defending the c-pawn
instead of the a-pawn
and as we already mentioned this c-pawn
might have a beautiful future
in the long run and it is what we would
call
a passer heavily guarded it's not a
protected passpond
there's no pawn protecting it but it is
very good
and also don't forget with this trade
for an apon for the sea now we've got a
clear
view on a7 not to mention
the b4 pawn can become a target as well
rook d8 bishop d4 queen a4
so the first part of
anderson's plan was accomplished he
got the control of that square on c5
got the right trade now he has to decide
which way to put pressure on a7 and b4
now of course we go rook a1
chasing the queen away and targeting the
seven pawn
queen d7 we do not want to get
into any x-ray business so anderson goes
queen f3
why does he go queen f3 and not
somewhere else
well the queen is sort of taking the
spot of the catalan bishop
it's going to lord over these squares
and potentially can support a c-pawn
push
combined with a potential bishop takes
f6
queen c7 and as we said bishop
takes f6 bishop takes f6
or k2 and if you recall from the
previous game
in this one we can get a very similar
situation blank has a bishop which
usually
is the preference to have
but the bishop really doesn't have a
clear target
the b2 pawn isn't as important as it
looks
because the knight is having a good
blockade in itself and it's not going to
be
as important so the catalan bishop
is the bishop that is usually on g2
and because it's gone we're substituting
it
i mean auth is substituting it with his
queen
rook a8 so now it's time for us
to come up with a plan
gallego would like to start strolling
down
with his pawns but it's not like an
immediate threat
we can still have some time to
optimize our pieces
it is sort of like the dragon bishop yes
so if you're talking about piece
optimization
which squares could we use
as some sort of booster square
so obviously when
we want to make sure our pieces
get extra power you centralize them
and ulf also follows these age-old rules
the queen in the center becomes all too
powerful
it attacks in all directions
and it takes away the e5 square
from gallego so that's why you want to
get
your pieces centralized because in that
case your opponent
can't do the same thing queen e4
g6 rook c1
just preparing that palm push and as we
all know
the rook is belonging behind
that c pawn now you couldn't take on b4
because of this neat little tactical
trick of rook b8
and if you move the queen over there
there's queen b7
check and then this queen takes b3
basically losing the game for white
now just because of anderson plays
a more strategical chess that doesn't
mean he doesn't
spot these tactics he is well aware
that he has to have these things under
control
rook c1 a5
so a chance is a lot of times about
understanding what your opponent is
about to do here
that pawn is about to roll
down the board so you've got to
make sure that you pay attention to your
opponent's threats
and not just blindly follow your own
idea
until it's too late
so here actually ulf rotates the plan
goes rk1 and says oh
i'm gonna stop your a-pawn i don't
want you to push it all the way through
if we would
allow a4 suddenly
this bishop would gain some strength and
would support
those passers so ulf
goes rook a1 just preventing that rook
db8
rook takes a5 rook takes a5
rook takes a5 bishop takes b2
and this seems like a fair trade
but it is not why not
well that b-pawn
is well blocked by this knight
there's no way you can push on through
so technically oaf is up upon
now is this does this objectively mean
that white is winning well not quite yet
white probably has the advantage but
there's still some work to be done
so in this position
we know we have the advantage what would
be
some ideas of how to continue here
don't forget there is this queen
blockading us
so if somehow we could remove it or
just chase it away potentially
we can promote the c pawn so that should
be our goal
right now it's difficult to do it with
queen f4 for example because of bishop
e5
so we have to find a roundabout way
yeah ro k8 very very good
you are trading you're not really
trading just to trade
the queen wants to show up on a5
chase the queen away i mean the dark
squared
uh queen away and once the queen
is there potentially c6 and c7
will be on the agenda so takes
queen takes king g7
now here of hesitates a little bit
decides to go back
probably didn't want the queen to go to
d5
that's often the problem and uh
that's why he goes queen e4 instead so
he changes plans
bishop c3 c6 and with no rooks
anymore on the board and this pawn on
the white squares
black has no ways of
consolidating king f8
queen c4 and talking about that
notice that most all of white's pieces
are stationed on the white squares so
this bishop
is literally without a job king e8
queen b5 eyeing that king
now if black would go king e7 white
could just go queen c5
queen d6 but this would straight run
into c7 and after takes
knight takes you do not have any entry
squares
to get to the c8 square and after the
pawn promotion
you're lost queen b5
bishop e5 so
you can see that anderson is slowly
but surely making headway even though
there are only queens and knights on the
board no rooks
barely any pawns left yet he is still
pressing
so what type of maneuvers would come to
mind
how could we potentially improve this
knight on b3
and you might be asking well isn't this
knight's
job to stop the b-pawn well not
necessarily
because our queen is right there
defending the c-pawn
and stopping the b-pawn from rolling
down so we will have
more ample time to activate
the b3 knight
yeah we can go something like knight c5
and knight a6
that's a very good plan trying to chase
the queen away and then
potentially threaten to go c7 and queens
or you could also go something like
knight a5 and knight c4
let's see how ulf does it knot a5
bishop d6 e4 there is no rush
gallego has no active plans if you move
the queen
c7 and you lose on the spot because
there's no way you can stop
this you're in a check and the next move
is c8 queens
so black is stuck defending here
black plays the move f6
which is somewhat of a mistake because
it weakens the pawns on e6 and f6
and gives extra chances for anderson
to infiltrate knight b3
king e7 knight d4 and for some it might
be confusing
why did he go knight a5 then suddenly
back
well he realized that with the pawn
moving to f6 there is no stable defender
for the e6 pawn
so this rotation makes a lot of sense
now
king e7 knight d4
e5 another move
that is somewhat impulsive by gallego
and anderson is getting very very close
to get a decisive advantage
and talking about e5 what is wrong with
that move
which square became absolutely
and devastatingly weakened
by e6 to e5
the d5 square this square
that wasn't weak at all before
becomes fatally weak now
and anderson wouldn't be the legendary
positional player if he didn't spot that
so he goes knight c2
b3 takes queen takes c6 and
even though we're getting into a
position with
no more uh
past spawn on c6 after knight e3
threats of knight d5 and the fact that
this king
and pawns are so weak means that gallego
still has to be very precise to defend
king f8 the knight hops
to that central square king g7
queen a2 and even though the pawns are
on the same side
the queen and knight does put a lot of
pressure on black's position queen b7
queen a4 probing to get on in there
king f7 queen c4
king g7 now they
are maneuvering a little bit
queen a6 queen b3
queen a5 now he's trying to get in there
on d8
now whenever you're looking at a
rook and game that four
for each side you usually anticipate a
draw
but the quality difference between this
knot on d5
and this bishop on d6 is so big that
anderson has winning chances in this
position
bishop e7 queen a4
king f7 and now
anderson takes his chance
takes his chance and finds
the biggest problem in gallagher's
position
goes queen c4
setting up a discovery gallego doesn't
want any part of that
but now here comes knight c7 and the
knight
is infiltrating and once the queen and
knight
do a combined attack on the king it is
game over
queen b4 and this was desperation by
gallego already
there is knight e8 check and the bishop
is overloaded you can't defend the queen
and the f6 spawn at the same time
and you can't go king f7 because
the queen is occupying and controlling
that
square f8 takes
takes knight takes f6
king f7 knight d5 bishop c5
so far so good anderson obviously
has big winning chances here but he
knows
he will not be able to win an end game
if he's not
bringing in the king so he brings that
king
up to the game and of course we'll try
to create a passer
with f2 f4 in the near future
here bishop d4 knight b4 but before that
he would do that he's going to maneuver
around
trying to find a good spot for the
knight itself
g5 gallego sees that
f4 is being prepared so he's stopping it
knight d5 g4 however there's a downside
to this
and that is he has to put those pawns on
white squares
which will never be really supported by
that d4 bishop
f3 now if you go
bishop g1 there is this idea of taking
taking knight e3 of course the ending is
completely one
for white but if you take here there's
king f2
and the bishop gets stuck in the corner
and there's no way to escape
so f3 g takes king takes king f7
knight e3 and what makes this play
so fascinating by anderson is his
undying love for these end games and his
patience he's very patient
even though he should be winning very
shortly
right now he's re-maneuvering this
knight to f5
where it will support the eventual pawn
break
king g6 g4 it's time for the trade
everything is ideally placed and h4 h5
is going to happen shortly h4 bishop c5
knight g3 trading it off take sticks
now the king is coming in there
and now trouble is brewing
knight e1 knight d3
bishop e3 knight c6 pressing on the e
pawn
in f6 knight b4
the knight is again heading towards the
d5 square
knight d3 bishop g3 king g4
king g5 just pushing this king away
and once the king reaches g6 you're lost
if you go king f7
there is king f5 and it's game over
so it's just
a matter of time till gallego has to
resign
h6 king f5 and here
of anderson the speed legend
one after 84 hard
fought moves so i really hope you
enjoyed these games which reflect
the catalan type of play especially
the ones between ribley and karpov and
the now 70 of anderson
hope you enjoyed this lesson and have a
beautiful
day or night wherever you are good night
and bye bye
[Music]
you